L W I A Y
*flattering intro*
LWIAY
L W I A Y
I'm looking forward to these videos every week now, because
so much things are just happening...
and what best way to summarise the week
by through memes!
"How do you get your news?"
Pewdiepie's submission sub-reddit
*One meme gone*
L e t ' s   j u s t   j u m p   i n t o   i t   g u y s !
Oh!! S(demonitized)
*Laugh*
*Chuckle*
Wait a minute!
Are you serio- Fifty one thousand upvotes?
This is the top vote, of all time!
Jesus Christ!
"My favourite part was when they did the fortnite dances in the suicide forest...
...but instead of corpses it's dead channels!
brilli- really outdone themselves this year!
*clap clap*
Thank you Dad, for finally supporting my channel.
jk
75,000,000, oh my God, I cant beli-*laughs* (finish your sentences Pewds)
It's at 76 (million) guys, learn fr*ckin math.
you idiots!
Mark-ass!
Maaarrkk-asss!
"AND MARK ASS BROWNLEE"
*Reads post*
You didn't deserve this, Mark-asss....
*r e a d s   p o s t *
SUBSCRIBE TO PEWDIEPIE
Oh yeah, I posted this on Twitter because so many people were pointing this out
but, Jaiden left even more references... Sub to Pewdiepie
I think that is a (smash letter?)
That's obviously the tied Logan Paul
Oh here we go... Is that Bitch Lasagna?
No way!
Ugandan knuckles!
That's awesome
*Reads Post*
I didn't see this! Are you kidding me?!?
No Marzia, no, please!
Finally, a game with good writing, goddamn
Fun fact, in Italy they call lasagna, "pastichio"
Oooh, I like the music!
you're always so nice and chipper!
As always, I feel like I have to check if there is anything on the left...
It's very pretty!
Look at the animations and everything, I love how my hair - Hey I'm collecting
*laughs*
Oh, it's glitching - *reads dialogue box*
Oh I thought they were boots, PEW GUNS (Hell yeaa)
Uuhhh, I'll put in 'O'
PEW PEW PEW, PEW PEEWW
Ey I am collecting monetization!
ARGH DEMONITIZATION!
(send help)
This is amazing.... *CHUCKLE*
This is dope!
I don't know how to open this...
Is this a puzzle?
I can't do puzzles, come on...
Can I push this? Oh I can
There you go, look at that
What is Edgar doing? "EDGAR WHAT ARE YOU DOING?" What is thaaaatt?
Ok I have something and I probably need it for...
Oh ok there we go.
Nice
Goddamn I am good at games, BYE!
Bye Edgar!
AAARGH!!!
YOUTUBE!
GODDAMN YOU YOUTUBE
I'm sorry.
HEY HEY HEY
NO
NO  NO
It took my monetization (T_T)
This is the most accurate
game of all time!
Is this going to be just a playthrough of this game ;-;
I complety forgot that I was supposed to do a LWIAY
oh god..
Edgar grab the..
..the thing!!
Thanks ;-;
I mean
I didnt wanna
its only a demo but ....
Game of the Yeaaaar???
lets not--
J A
G O D D A M M I T Y O U T U B E ):<
IM SICK OF YOUR S***
GOD F****** DAMMIT YOUTUBE
stop getting me demonetized )-:
FLEX GUN
FLEX TIMMMMMMEEEE
Edgar is about as useless as tails in sonic
E
god f****** dammit
not like this
don't do me like this markiplier >:(
Oh god I'm dead
I'm actually gonna die
sTop E-ing me!
Oh my god I actually died
thats alright (:
what
hELL yeah!
how do I activate it??
OH
OOoohh
ChAiRR
AHHHAHA
AHHHA *pewds laughs*
YESS!
this changes everyth- OH I CAN SPIN
I CAN SPIN GODDAMMIT
GET OUTTA MY WAY BRAD
$399!!
10-ine outta 10
10/10
now we gotta go back into the memes
no I did not- look up a tutorial
because I got stuck ok ?? >:(
goddammit thank you so much that's amazing
STOP SENDING ME LOOK ALIKE PICTURES >:((((
I know I look like any average Swedish person on the planet
but that's RACIST
*reads post*
They literally do twelve hour shoots for a two second clip.
I mean how much money do you? They must spend an insane amount of money on the Rewinds.
Wait I gotta show you guys- you've probably seen this
Justin Bieber's "Baby" video is getting almost three hundred thousand dislikes taken off in one day
due to people wanting Rewind 2018 as the most disliked video is the perfect example of how to turn the hate
of another thing is the fastest way into clear hate
Guys, sometimes we gotta make sacrifices here, we gotta go to the Justin Bieber "Baby" video
Did I actually-I'm curious if I actually disliked it.
and we've gotta remove-I Disliked it!-It's time to remove our dislikes.
Moving on, and so it begins "YouTuber PewDiePie calls Lilly Singh a 'Crybaby' after she speaks out about wage
inequality." How about this title, YouTuber PewDiePie rightfully calls out Lilly Singh because she is a crybaby.
How's that for a title for a change huh?
"At Melbourne, Australia, doing our part."
Hit or miss, I guess they never miss huh?
"She recently hit 5 million subscribers. Can we push her channel to 6 million just because she sneaked
PewDiePie's chair into YouTube Rewind?"
Can we increase the size of this channel by a fifth just for a meme guys, I mean why not that's practically
what's happening with my channel
"We are doing our part in Hungary."
"Sub to Pewds = free muffin"
Damn. Damn.
"1% of the world is now subscribed to PewDiePie"
I mean obviously that isn't right because there's a lot of duplicate accounts and a lot of dead people
and *clears throat*
"Can you un-rewind? A celebrity in rewind, a Twitch streamer in rewind, a YouTuber who hasn't posted in
7-9 months" let's make her the face of Rewind
"A YouTube who has made videos for almost a decade, became the most" uh daily can I add that, daily.
"became the most subscribed Youtuber for 5 years, donated to Indian 9 year-olds, but still not in Rewind?
This is so sad, where was y'all at when I was... in the... uh?
"What the fricking frack happened to your office?"
I'm gonna add some stuff to it, I'm just trying to figure it out, don't worry okay.
Stop complaining!
"Very underrated comment 'It's called YouTube Rewind because the quality keeps going backwards every year'"
*clap* *clap*
"Journalists writing articles about Pewds be like 'Reality can be whatever I want.'''
I mean, 100% accuracy meme status everyone.
*clap* *clap*
..has this goddamn picture.
I mean, I guess
it could be worse.
But..